la coalition avenir québec promettent
d'aider les familles québécoises qui
désirent avoir plus d'enfants salon
françois legault il s'agit là d'une très
bonne façon de stimuler la croissance de
l'économie
une augmentation des naissances ben
c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le québec
ça veut dire une économie plus fort
monsieur legault a ses raisons de faire
un lien entre augmentation des
naissances et croissance économique
de 2000 à 2010 est le québec a connu une
croissance annuelle d'environ 1,6 pour
cent en moyenne et durant cette période
là le bassin de main-d'oeuvre potentiel
la population âgés entre 15 et 64 ans a
augmenté annuellement de 0 5%
mais comme le québec vieillit et que
depuis cinquante ans de prépa assez
d'enfants pour compenser ce bassin de
main-d'oeuvre potentiel a commencé à
diminuer
on compte au québec de moins en moins de
personnes en âge de travailler
si rien ne change au cours des dix
prochaines années la population âgés
entre 15 et 64 ans va diminuer de 0,2
pour cent en moyenne à chaque année si
rien ne change on nous prédit un taux de
croissance annuel d'à peine 0,9 pour
cent pour les dix prochaines années
c'est d'aider les familles françois
legault en raison encourager les
naissances peut freiner la baisse de la
population en âge de travailler et avoir
un impact positif sur l'économie mais il
s'agit d'une solution à long terme même
si cette politique nataliste fonctionne
il va falloir attendre entre 15 ou 20
ans avant que ses enfants intègrent le
marché du travail et c'est maintenant
qu'il faut combler les postes
disponibles à court terme
il ya d'autres options comme encourager
les 55 ans et plus à rester plus
longtemps sur le marché du travail
encourager les entreprises à investir
dans la productivité faire plus avec
moins de travailleurs qui surtout
accueillir suffisamment des migrants et
bien les intégrer au marché du travail
actuellement le tournage des nouveaux
arrivants est deux à trois fois plus
élevé que le taux chômage de l'ensemble
du québec
maintenant voici notre adresse